Irina Petrovna is making a flurry of
last-minute preparations
I brought a hundred young people along
she says cadets the candles of
remembrance ceremony will last for three
hours we do it in memory of all those
who perished during the siege of
leningrad in World War two I asked about
the cold it doesn't bother us she says
we're used to it we'll stay for the
fireworks these women are looking
forward to the fireworks
for a few days st. Petersburg is taking
on its Soviet name Leningrad the city
remembers one of the greatest and
deadliest episodes of world war ii the
forces of Nazi Germany surrounded the
city from September 1941 until January
1944 an estimated 1 million people died
nearly half of Leningrad population I
visit one of the survivors branislav
eval area Nova lives on the outskirts of
st. Petersburg I brought this bouquet
for you
she's been expecting me the polite
hostess makes us a pot of tea branislav
eval area Nova is 80 she lives in a
modest apartment even after so many
years
hers is an epic story Valeria Nova was 7
when the German Wehrmacht launched its
two and a half year siege Leningrad was
cut off from the outside world and one
by one the young girl lost her family
within months the grandparents died of
starvation then her father and finally
her mother all that remains of
photographs and memories
Valeria Nova shows me a picture of her
mother in happier times she was 27 when
the snapshot was taken the war began one
year later and Valeria Nova's mother
died at age 28
her father ignored the orders of Soviet
authorities to evacuate the city his
fateful decision would soon turn the
seven year old into an orphan she tells
me that they would boil furniture paste
to eat one day the plates were on the
table but her mother didn't return
from the bathroom the girl called out
that there was no answer she found her
mother dead on the floor after that she
was alone and soon there was no more
furniture paste so she soared up chairs
and ate the sawdust then there was no
more wood and nothing more to eat she
tells me she wrote letters to relatives
asking them to save her letters never
arrived after the war Valeria Nova
learned to be a cook she vowed never to
go hungry again we traveled to the city
center to the area where Valeria Nova
lived during the war these days she
can't afford to live in the historic
district rents are too high her
retirement pays just enough to cover a
one-room apartment outside the city
she's angered by the injustice of it all
look at all the war memorials she
laments there is money to build them but
not to take care of survivors I have no
reason to celebrate she says someday I
will die and no one will remember me as
we drive into the old part of town
memories come alive of childhood and the
war she tells me she'd love to see the
family's apartment but she's convinced
they'd never let her in the neighbors
she grew up with are all dead and the
new residents would surely look at her
as an alien via dress genichesk I uh uh
lead sir number five the apartment
building survived intact despite a
continuous barrage of German artillery
Valeria Nova tells me the facade has
changed little since the war she tells
me she loved living here the children
played hide and seek in the courtyard
and skipped rope in the sunshine I asked
Valeria Nova whether she ever returned
after the war's end yes she replies in
1948 it was a warm and emotional home
everything is new and different here she
says even the doorbell
she's clearly nervous her heart is
pounding after a few minutes the door
opens and immediately shuts again the
new tenant is in no mood for uninvited
guests everything's changed she tells me
outside she guides me down to the never
river she tells me water was the one
thing they had plenty of during the
nearly 900 day siege this is where
people got water she says there were
long lines here in the winter the number
of water runs per day were determined
simply by how big the buckets were
Valeria Nova remembers that she only had
a small jar and had to run up and down
the stairs several times per day she
recalls that in the winter of 1942 the
steps were slick with ice no.1 boiled
the river water and rations amounted to
125 grams of bread per day to survive
Valeria Nova gathered and ate almost
anything she could to be softened with
water wallpaper glue paper shoe leather
tree bark and paste
overpowered by memories of that time
Valeria Nova asks that I take her back
home we agree to meet again in the
evening I'll attend the commemoration
ceremonies alone in the old city center
I encounter sandbags and barbed wire
it's an attempt to recreate the ambience
of the blockade officials call it
historic reconstruction military
vehicles are on display along with
images of the war years as Samba music
sets the tone
a city guide brings me back to the here
and now a snapshot with a soldier
impersonator taken in front of an actual
bus from the time period it's proving to
be a popular tourist attraction this
woman is a tourist visiting to make sure
that this historic day will not be
forgotten I asked her what she finds so
important about it she replies that the
pain suffered here should never be
repeated the atmosphere here is almost
carnival like
the historic reconstruction has
attracted mostly young people the city
of st. Petersburg spent nearly six
million euros for the anniversary
observation opposition leaders
criticized it as wasted revenue they say
the funds should have gone to increase
pensions for the survivors by meet with
city councilman Boris Vishnevsky he's a
busy man but he makes one thing clear
he says it's disgusting to finance a
recreation of this kind the siege led to
suffering starvation bombs and the
painful deaths of so many people he says
the city has turned this into some kind
of happy spectacle made of plastic and
paper he rejects it as tasteless and
unworthy my next question touches a
nerve I asked him if commemorations like
these serve as a source of pride for
modern Russians and whether it's a way
to display strength and influence the
world over Vishnevsky then becomes angry
he replies that true strength can only
be proven through culture scientific
achievement and education not by
historic recreations
most citizens of st. Petersburg think
differently they say celebrations like
this are important especially to give
younger generations a feel for the true
horrors of war I meet some young people
on some Petersburg's lavish nevsky
prospekt shopping Boulevard the candles
of remembrance observation gets underway
soon beginning with a minute's silence
usually the noise level here is
ear-splitting now rare quiet
fireworks over the river neva cap a big
day
but one person hasn't attended branislav
eval area north nur Ivanova
survivor of the siege of leningrad she
just can't summon the strength still she
has dressed up for the occasion perhaps
her grandchildren will drop by after the
fireworks are over until then she says
she'll have her own celebration watching
television this is my life she tells me